I'd love to pivot,
yeah, I said it,
and ask you guys a round robin of questions.
You ready?
(Ginnifer laughing)
Ready.
I'm ready.
I'm nervous, but I'm ready.
Okay, Ginnifer, it's a rainy Sunday.
What are you doing?
Baking bread. Making jam.
Ooh. Oh God, that's so good.
Okay, Eliza, what is your go-to indulgence these days?
Cheese?
Yes. Spread it all over.
I love cheese.
(Maggie laughing)
Maggie, what is your most used emoji?
Oh, the laughing one
with the two tears.
Yes. Okay.
Ginnifer, who is most like their character on "Pivoting"?
The author.
(Ginnifer laughing)
Because it is autobiographical.
Abort mission!
We all are terrible choices as characters on this show.
That's true.
I love that,
'cause that actually, like,
if you tell the truth and you tell your story,
it's gonna be better.
All right, Eliza,
what is the most embarrassing text on your phone right now?
Oh, maybe the last one I just sent to the girls
(group laughing)
About cheese.
I'm really just keeping with this cheese storyline
for me, and I used to be vegan.
So this was a whole thing.
I love it.
I know life without cheese is a really hard life.
Okay, Maggie, have you ever ghosted someone?
No.
Oh, that's so nice.
Okay, Ginnifer, if you had the power of invisibility,
what would be the first thing you would do?
I think that I would probably, I mean,
I should probably be, like,
seeing what my kids are watching
on television when I'm not in the room.
Oh my God. That's so true.
It's so true. Okay.
Eliza, who is the most surprising person
to slide into your DMs?
Oh, I can't divulge that information.
(group laughing)
But it's always good.
I know!
I know who it is! Just kidding.
Oh, I know who it is!
Okay, but it's someone.
It is. Oh, it is someone.
Maggie, who was a fun on-screen kiss?
(Maggie groaning)
I hate on-screen kissing.
I know, it's so weird. We all know this.
Okay, you guys all know this,
and I know no one's gonna believe us,
but it's the most uncomfortable situation to be in.
No offense, men.
It's true. It's not sexy.
Very un-sexy.
It's the worst.
All right.
Well, oh, okay.
Ginnifer, when's the last time you got caught in a lie?
Oh, the last time I got caught in a lie.
Oh, it was recently,
and it was somebody gave me a gift,
and I hadn't actually opened it,
and then I was asked about how I used it,
and I had to guess at what it was,
and I was wrong.
(group laughing)
I love that. Eliza, what's your favorite song right now?
It's an instrumental Hermanos Gutierrez song.
Yeah.
Oh wow.
I was not expecting that.
Okay, Maggie, has a pick-up line ever worked on you,
and if so, what was it?
People very, very rarely hit on me,
number one, let's get that out of the way,
and then number two,
the ones who do do the lines, I feel like,
or ever have, are doing it as a semi-joke,
because the chance of rejection,
you see what I'm saying, is very high,
and so they put it out there,
and then there's a laugh, and then it's over.
Yeah. Yeah.
I know, I can't believe no one ever asks you out, Maggie.
I mean, if that just, if you don't get asked out,
good luck for the rest of us.
Okay. Last round.
Ginnifer, has anyone ever recognized you,
and you made an excuse and ran away?
Oh my gosh. I used to, and you know what?
I started feeling like, that is,
I started feeling really guilty about doing that.
I used to think that I was
preserving privacy in some way,
by denying who I was and running off,
and then I felt like even someone asking me if I'm me
is a kindness, because what they are expressing,
in some ways, you are familiar,
because I've probably seen something that you have done,
and to that, I should be saying, "Thank you",
and so to that, I now say, "Yes, it is me".
Okay. Eliza, what's one thing
you only do when you're alone?
Oh, yeah. I mean, take a bath.
I'm not doing that with other people.
(audience laughing)
Maggie, have you ever used a bogus excuse
to get out of a date, and if so, what was it?
Yeah, I think I once said I would go,
'cause I don't usually do one-on-one dating.
That's very, very rare for me. It just almost never happens.
So it's always like a group of people,
it was like a medical,
I made a medical excuse to get out of the dinner.
Okay, first of all,
I love the group dating dynamic.
You're right why aren't we like,
what's wrong with us?
Too much pressure.
We're here talking about friendship,
and support, and parachuting,
and we're going on dates by ourselves.
I think you just-
Don't you think
it kills so many birds without killing any birds,
because you sort of,
I need to know what my friends think anyway,
so why wouldn't you just meet in a group?
And if immediately they're like,
"That's not gonna work for us",
then you also know, and then it's done,
and then you don't have to.
This is the best screening process ever!
You guys, I'm not kidding.
(audience applauding)
Let's start a movement!
Oh, we should.
(audience applauding)
I love this.
Ginnifer Goodwin, Eliza Coupe, Maggie Q!
"Pivoting" airs Thursdays at 9:30 on Fox.
(upbeat music)